you
your Majesties your Royal Highness
laureates ladies and gentlemen
data installed era at four present
ii-era labelled please target and
literature it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureate in
literature sir VS Naipaul
[Applause]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
honored laureates ladies and gentlemen
one of the things that happened to
people who get the Nobel Prize is that
they also get a lot of media attention
many interviews too many so many that I
begin to feel now that I have lost the
capacity for spontaneous thought I need
the questions and since they're not
going to be any questions now I thought
I would begin the two-minute speech
which is meant to be like like the
old-fashioned comedian the man you know
to whom things happened on the way to
the studio well then something happened
to me on the way to Stockholm the strap
of my wristwatch broke and for some
surreal moments I found myself looking
at my watch of the floor of the plane
this is no metaphor here is the
strapless watch
what did it mean what was the awful
symbolism the fact that all through this
grand noble week I was to be without my
watch the great Caesar Landing in Egypt
fell flat on his face on the wet show
you can imagine the consternation of his
officers until the great and resourceful
man shouted Africa I've got you some
centuries later the Emperor Julian
training one morning with his soldiers
lost the Wicker part of his shield he
was left holding only the grip of the
handle how terrible for everybody until
the Emperor shouted what I have I hold
not having the resourcefulness of these
great men I could find no words to make
the bad symbolism good until tonight
when I understood that time was the stop
for me during this noble week and that
when it began again it would be truly
new now my strapless watch be nine again
tells me without threat that my time is
running out my two minutes up
you
[Music]